catch and kill lies spies and a
conspiracy to protect predators Ronan
Farrow thanks for being here
good to be here thanks Brett I want to
start chronologically when you start to
uncover the depth of the allegations
against Harvey Weinstein how much
pressure are you starting to feel at
that point very rapidly I experienced
and this is not just me this is backed
up by a paper trail that is uncovered in
this book by the account of my
working-level producer who has come out
publicly and said I witnessed all of
this there was a shutdown strange signs
of interference that then became
explicit orders to stop and look we had
a story that journalists looked at and
said this should get on air immediately
we had a recorded admission of guilt
from Harvey Weinstein secured during a
police sting operation we had multiple
named women and every draft of this
story there have been miss
characterizations and down playings of
what we had but that's actually not the
point the point is what you hit on this
was a case where a news organization
didn't behave journalistically they
ordered us to stop to not take so much
as a call and to cancel interviews in
some cases with alleged rape victims
this book explains why I want to talk
about NBC in a second you know how he
mentioned the Hillary Clinton connection
at one time you worked for Hillary
Clinton you were doing an interview on a
separate project her spokesman calls and
says that they had concerns about the
Weinstein story at NBC did you feel
pressure from Hillary Clinton on this
you know like everything else in the
book Brett this is handled in a very
measured way the book is meticulously
fact-checked we had long conversations
with everyone discussed in it including
Hillary Clinton's people and it is
extremely fair to her now it's rendered
I can't speak to her state of mind what
I can say is that she attempted to
withdraw from an interview that she had
committed to for a foreign policy book
that I was working on for which I
interviewed every other living Secretary
of State and before doing so her staff
raised concerns about the fact that I
was working on this story about one of
her most significant donors a big
bundler of Hollywood money when NBC
kills your story are you demoralized do
you think it's gonna see the light of
day the fundamental fact here is that I
took reporting that this network had
looked at and you can read the book for
yourself and see whether you agree
with their judgment that it shouldn't of
air and took it across the street to the
New Yorker and in just a matter of weeks
it became a Pulitzer Prize winning
significant body of reporting and I owe
that to the bravery of sources I owe it
to incredible editors there and I think
that it tells an important story about
the circles of mutual protection and
power in our business in the media and
the need to hold ourselves accountable
that's true of CBS where I did reporting
on allegations of misconduct there and
secret settlements there it's true of
Fox your own Network which has done a
great job of confronting some of the
issues here including the use of secret
settlements and now there's a tough
conversation happening at NBC where
after I've unveiled that there were in
years where they claimed no secret
settlements in fact many of them
including ones with Matt Lauer's
accusers and the journalists there who
are excellent journalists in many cases
are asking tough questions about why you
know NBC is calling the book a smear
they flatly deny that it that NBC knew
about the Lauer allegations before he
was fired in the wake of this rape
allegation which Lauer denies putting
out a statement saying for two years the
women with whom I had extramarital
relationships have abandoned shared
responsibility and instead shielded
themselves from blame behind false
allegations they've avoided having to
look a boyfriend husband or child in the
eye and say I cheated they have done
enormous damage in the process and I
will no longer provide them shelter of
my silence when you saw that release
what were you thinking you know one of
the things I respect about your coverage
Brett it is is it is very measured this
book attempts at all times to be
maximally fair and it incorporates
responses of the type that you just read
throughout we spent many many hours
discussing all of this with NBC
leadership and every party discussed in
the book none of these responses are a
surprise because they are in there
alongside to be paper trail that I
document and the meticulously
fact-checked reporting and I'll let the
facts speak for themselves I'm very
confident in the reporting in the book
and it has held up to scrutiny from
multiple news organizations now a lot of
organizations go through this have to
deal with this you mentioned and trust
us we know here at Fox we've had to deal
with it as well but do you think the
executives at NBC have sort of gotten a
pass having to deal with this conference
River
see about how it's being covered in the
press I do not see a pass happening
right now
I think the hopeful part of this story
and the hopeful part of this book catch
and kill is that it is about the
continuing unstoppable bravery of women
speaking out about this issue at many
important institutions it is about the
bravery of reporters who refused to stop
and many of their stories not just my
own run through catch and kill so while
yes this is about crimes and cover-ups
and circles of power that protect each
other it's also about the fact that I
think the truth will keep coming and
right now we are seeing a really tough
conversation about the need for
accountability in media you've been very
outspoken about the sexual misconduct
allegations against your father Woody
Allen who denies any wrongdoing but
taking on the sexual misconduct seems to
be have become almost your life's work
is is your upbringing part of what
drives you on this topic you know on the
one hand I'm a lawyer by training Brett
and much of the reporting I do has not
been on sexual violence it's been on all
sorts of misconduct and malfeasance and
corruption and I view the reporting that
I do on sexual violence as being just
another form of investigative reporting
where you have to be adversarial and
tough and skeptical and interrogate the
facts on the other hand I very openly
discuss in this book how I myself
struggled with this painful part of my
history how it was weaponized against me
by people like Harvey Weinstein who
threw it into things like legal threat
letters you know his sister was sexually
assaulted
he can't report on these stories
objectively that is not the case that's
not what any journalist has thought what
is the case is that I cared about this
issue profoundly and I came to
understand very gradually as someone who
had once told a person in my life maybe
you should just shut up about this and
not face the blowback that actually in
the end I came to understand that I was
wrong and my sister was right and that
the many brave women speaking out were
right I am grateful to every source
every whistleblower who comes my way I
try to do justice to the evidence they
bring me and that includes women with
these kinds of elevate you know there
are some media critics and who looked at
some of the reporting about the Brett
Kavanaugh accusers and and came to the
conclusion that it wasn't up to your
usual Stan
and may have been rushed a bit because
you didn't like Cavanaugh or something
that that's what the critics had said I
just want you to address some of that
yeah media perspective quite the
contrary
you know the coverage of Brett Kavanaugh
is something that I'm very proud of and
that follows a body of reporting that
mostly has focused on unflattering
information about Democrats when I
report a story it is about ferreting out
the truth and in this case you know
subsequent analysis by other
publications including two New York
Times reporters who just dug into this
for a year and found deborah ramirez
credible one of the alleged victims of
Brett Kavanaugh that I wrote about you
know the consensus has I think come to
understand that the individual careful
pieces of reporting that I put out were
there because it was newsworthy and
there was a high level of corroboration
now that said I want to note something
about the media climate around this
there were dubious claims that I
declined to report on and that were out
there in the context of that frenzied
political fight over that confirmation
and that is deeply disturbing to me I
was as troubled as all of the people who
came to question the full body of
reporting about Brett Kavanaugh but the
complicated case there was that there
were allegations worth reporting on and
I did so carefully along with colleagues
of mine as well as a frenzied political
climate where I think there were
spurious allegations quite possibly
being made the book is catching caroline
spires and conspiracy to protect
predators it is quite a read ronan we
appreciate you coming on special report
thank you brett really appreciate it